- Good afternoon, everyone.
I am delighted to invite you all
to the postdoc discussion
after Jenann Ismael's talk yesterday.
And welcome to both Jenann
and Jim Woodward,
who is the discussant this afternoon.
Ty, I would like to
now turn it over to you
to formally introduce them.
Thank you.
- Sure, thank you.
Thanks, Professor Natarajan.
So again, you may recall from yesterday,
those of you who had joined us,
that Professor Ismael
received her doctorate
from Princeton University.
She was a Mellon fellow
at Stanford and taught
at the University of Arizona
before coming to Columbia.
She's held a number of
prestigious fellowships,
including an NEH Fellowship
at the National Humanities Center,
a Queen Elizabeth II Research Fellowship
from the Australian Research Council,
and fellowships from
the Templeton Foundation
and the Center for Advanced
Studies in Behavioral Science
at Stanford.
Her conversant today is
professor James Woodward,
distinguished professor in
the department of history
and philosophy of science at
the University of Pittsburgh.
Before coming to Pittsburgh
in the fall of 2010,
Professor Woodward was the J. O.
and Juliette Koepfli professor
of humanities at Caltech.
He's a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
a fellow of the
American Association for
the Advancement of Science
and a fellow at the
Center for Advanced Study
in the Social and Behavioral Sciences,
a position he held
actually from 2015 to 2016.
From 2010 to 2012, he served as president
of the Philosophy of Science Association.
In 2005, he was awarded
an award for making things happen,
a Making Things Happen Award
from the laka, Lakatos,
sorry, Jim, Lakatos Award.
So we're very delighted to
have him and very much looking
forward to the post-talk discussion.
A video of this will be available
on our Inference Project
website in about a week's time.
So without further ado,
happy to turn it over to you, Jim.
- Thank you.
- I would just like to
request everyone else
to switch off their videos,
please, and their audios.
Thank you very much.
- Okay, shall I try to get things started
by initiating this conversation?
Would that be-
- Absolutely.
- Okay, so one of the themes
in your talk yesterday,
at least as I understood it, Jenann,
was something like the following,
that there are different
ways of approaching the topic
of causation and causal the
reasoning in philosophy.
One way, which is associated with kind
of standard analytic philosophy,
analytic metaphysics, et cetera,
is to ask such questions
as, what is causation?
Or what is included in
our concept of causation?
And then you would do, if
you're doing the latter,
you would do some sort
of conceptual analysis
of our concept of causation.
But there's an alternative way
of approaching the subject of causation.
You can ask questions about
the role that causation plays
in our lives, how causal reasoning
and causal thinking figures in,
so to speak, the psychological
economy of human agents.
You can ask that question.
You can ask the question of
what the physical underpinning,
so to speak, of causal thinking are.
That it switched the
worldly infrastructure or the
things that have to be true
of the world for causal
reasoning to be successful.
You emphasized, I think,
both of these in your talk.
I would add a third component,
which is more normative in character.
There are also questions
about what are the strategies
or procedures that make a causal reasoning
or learning about causal relationships
from certain kinds of data reliable?
And if you're doing these latter things,
rather than the analytic
metaphysics project,
things really look rather different.
There are different criteria for success.
The whole focus is different.
The focus is more, it's
psychological, anthropological.
If you're interested in the
normative aspects of things,
there are connections
with work in statistics
on causal reasoning, work
in machine learning and AI
on causal learning, et cetera, et cetera.
So I thought maybe one way
we can get started would,
just to talk a little bit about this,
at least as I see it, distinction
between these two ways
of going at this general topic
of trying to understand
causation and causal reasoning.
And then there's a further question,
which I think is interesting,
about whether if you do
think that there's some merit
in this alternative way
of approaching things
that I'm describing,
whether that might be
extended to other notions
that are of philosophical interest.
- So I'm in complete agreement with you
about the latter project.
That that's certainly the one
that I've been engaged in.
I think one of the
things that happens when
you're doing the kind of
standard analytic metaphysics approach
is that you start with
a conceptual analysis,
with what causation looks like from
a conceptual point of view.
And then you look in the world that
is the world as described by physics,
and you try to see
whether there's anything
that satisfies that description.
And very often precisely
because the subject
and relationship between the subject
and the world has kind of gone out of you,
you don't find anything
that directly satisfies that description.
So I think it's not only
that there are these two
alternative projects,
but there's a way in
which the former project
is kind of bound to fail,
that comes into view when you're doing
the latter kind of project.
The part that I didn't talk about it,
the part where you're
treating it as a normative,
you're looking for sort of
normative guidance about things
like causal search and
inference strategies.
That's not something that
I talked about at all.
It is something that you talk a lot about
in your new book, which I.
And I wonder if you don't mind just taking
a couple of minutes to talk about that,
since the book isn't out.
And I've had a peek at some of it.
I think people would be really interested
to hear sort of something about that.
- Okay. Well, thank you.
So the book is called
"Causation with a Human Face:
Normative Theory and
Descriptive Psychology."
And it's forthcoming with
Oxford in the middle of October.
And so what I try to do in the book,
it's a mixture of a lot
of different things,
but one of the central
projects or themes is to try
to bring together what I think of
as normative work about
causation and causal reasoning.
And I see this going on,
as I said earlier,
in statistics, in machine learning,
machine discovery of causal relationships.
And I also actually think a fair amount
of the philosophical work that's been done
on causation is really,
the best way to understand
it is as normative proposals
of various kinds.
So there's a certain tendency, I think,
particularly in analytic metaphysics,
to think that the
project is somehow some
kind of descriptive one,
purely descriptive one that
is a description either
of our concept of causation
or maybe a description of,
let's say like people in
this tradition like to say,
causal reality or what causation is.
And I think putting things that way faces
what in fact is a kind
of normative component.
The normative component being
that these are actually
proposals about how you want
to reason, think about causation.
They're not just purely descriptive.
So anyway, there's this
normative component
that comes out of the disciplines
that I just described.
And then there's a huge
burgeoning amount of work going on
in cognitive psychology,
developmental psychology,
to some extent in the
animal learning literature.
There's work in primatology,
et cetera, et cetera,
which is, and to some
extent also neurobiology,
which is descriptive of the sorts
of things that go on
that when people engage
in causal reasoning,
the kinds of causal
judgements people make,
the procedures, cognitive and otherwise,
that they go through when they
make causal judgements.
And one of the things that
I try to do in the book
is to bring these two
literatures together.
And one of the ways in
which I think they can
be brought together is
if you're willing to adopt
what might be described
as a kind of rational actor
model of causal cognition.
And the basic idea here,
and this fits with the general theme
that causation is this functional notion
that we use all the
time in our daily lives.
The idea is that people,
when they engage in causal reasoning,
are often successful.
They do things in, at
least to some extent,
and in some respects, are
normatively appropriate.
So you can then connect the
normative and the descriptive
by asking such questions as, well,
a normative theory says that
the appropriate way to reason
in such and such a situation is so and so,
let's go look and see
whether people actually
in fact reason in that way.
And a whole lot of psychology experiments
have exactly this form.
And you do see a certain amount of
rationality or normatively
appropriate behavior
in people's causal reasoning.
You can also go in the other direction.
If you find people doing
something regularly
in their causal cognition,
and you have a theory that suggests that
it's either completely
normatively inappropriate
or maybe your theory says
nothing at all about whether
it's normatively appropriate at all,
then that can provide an impetus
to ask the question, well,
maybe we should rethink our
normative theory a little bit.
Maybe we're missing something
in our normative accounts.
So I see these kind of back
and forth interactions going on
between the normative and the descriptive.
And so I try to emphasize in the book,
this isn't a matter of
deriving a not from an
is or anything like that.
It's rather that if you're willing
to make appropriate
additional assumptions,
like for example, the
rational actor assumption,
then you can connect the
normative and descriptive.
So that is one of the themes in the book.
And obviously my focus on the
psychology of causal inference
is very much in the spirit of
kind of putting the subject
or the human agent back into the picture,
that the focus is on,
at least in part, on what we try to do
with causal reasoning.
What are the goals?
What are the functions?
What is it we're trying to accomplish
when we engage in causal reasoning?
So that's one theme in the book.
Another theme in the
book, just very quickly,
is a certain skepticism about the tendency
in at least a lot of
contemporary analytic philosophy
to make a very sharp distinction
between metaphysics and epistemology.
You certainly see this to some extent
in the analytic metaphysics
literature on causation,
and indeed on a lot of other topics,
where the idea is that what causation is
should be understood in some
way that it's totally divorced
from how we might find out about it.
And this, for reasons that I,
you can perhaps guess that,
I won't try to go into them in detail.
Now that strikes me as
not a very fruitful way of
approaching the subject.
Okay, so another theme in
your discussion yesterday,
Jenann was what might be called
the worldly underpinnings or
the physical infrastructure
that underlies causal reasoning.
And I take it you emphasize in particular
the role of something like
thermodynamic gradients, and so on,
and the way in which
human agents are situated
in time and in this entropy gradient.
Could you say a little
bit more about that,
and maybe also just
about the whole project
of talking about physical underpinnings?
I myself have some thoughts about that,
and I'm actually working on a paper
with some other people
in connection with that.
And I think it's an interesting project,
and it's obviously, again,
rather different from asking, well,
what belongs to the concept
of causation and what doesn't?
It's more like,
what are the preconditions
that have to be present
in the world for causal reasoning
to be possible and successful?
- Right, yeah, so the way, I mean,
the way it sort of comes
up in the philosophy
of physics literature is
that for some time just
in the course of doing physics,
it became clear that there were
these high-level generalizations captured
in thermodynamics that had to be,
in some way, reconcile.
That because they
incorporated it temporarily,
symmetry had to be in some way reconciled
with the underlying time
symmetric physical laws.
And what it means to say
that the underlying laws
are time symmetric,
it means that for any
physically possible trajectory
that goes from a state at
time T1 to a state at time T2,
there's a physically possible
reverse of that trajectory.
So one that goes from state S2 at T2,
sorry, from S2,
which is the final state in the original,
to the initial state in the original.
But of course we look around us
and we see all sorts of
temporarily asymmetric processes.
It became sort of widely accepted that all
of the temporarily asymmetric processes
that we actually see are
the ones that are captured
by the second law of thermodynamics.
There's might be some
wiggle room about that,
but they capture by far the largest body
of, say, temporarily
asymmetric physical phenomena
in the world.
So the project of
reconciling the second law
of thermodynamics, which are
time symmetric underlying laws,
was for a long time just a
straightforward physics project.
One that took a long time.
There were a lot of kind of missteps
in the early history of thermodynamics,
but probably in the last 50 or 60 years,
it really started to come into focus.
Okay, now when we look at
agents and in particular,
the first person kind of
perspective on the world
from the point of view
of an embedded agent,
we find two very striking
asymmetries that are kind
of pervasive from a
first-person point of view.
One is the asymmetry of knowledge,
and the other is a causal asymmetry.
They asymmetry of
knowledge is this idea that
we remember the (mic thuds),
sorry, we remember the past.
We don't remember the future.
We know more about the past we
than we do about the future.
It takes some time to actually give
a precise characterization of these,
but take that as a rough and ready go.
The other one is obviously
the causal asymmetry,
the idea that we think that from
a first-person point of view,
we think that we can affect
the future by acting some way
in the here and now, but not the past.
And the question arose quite naturally,
are those in some way connected
to the asymmetry of thermodynamics?
- Great, but, a quick
question though, Jenann.
There's a fundamental
difference between the past
and the present in terms of
access to information, right?
That you cannot circumvent
no matter what, right?
And that's of course tied to
the directionality of time,
and so on.
But, I mean, is it useful to see it as
about being about information
rather than entropy,
or are they interchangeable?
I'm just curious.
- So, I mean,
these were the questions that
people were asking, right?
So I think the most illuminating
way to understand it
is to think in terms
of what kind of information is
there available in the world
for an agent of the kind that has access
to its local environment to use?
If you ask the question that way,
then you do get a natural answer.
And the natural answer is
something like this, right?
So if you're just looking
at the macroscopic structure
of the world, I mean,
this is the one I went over
very quickly during the talk,
but the slightly more
detailed answer is this.
If you're looking at the
macroscopic structure of the world,
and you assume that an
agent only has sort of,
whatever you think direct access is,
if you think there's some
sort of direct perceptual,
that is there some basic
notion of information
that comes from some sort of
causal channel with the world
on the part of an agent,
those are the perceptual channels.
If you take information that's
coming through that channel
and you ask yourself,
what can an agent, in
a generic physically,
a generic world that
obeys the Newtonian laws,
what can an agent like
that know about the rest
of the world?
What can an agent that has that kind of
contemporary causal contact
with its own local environment
parlay into in terms of knowledge
of the rest of the world?
Assume just to be, I mean,
to make it a kind of
in principle question,
assume it knows the physical laws.
And ask what can it infer
from local information
about its environment?
So you say,
what can it infer as a matter
of physical, almost nothing.
Everything that it can infer
depends on what's going on
in other places.
It depends on,
we know as a matter of physical
law that the total state
of the world at one time,
if it's known,
can allow an agent that
knows the physical laws,
to know everything about
the past and future,
but we also know that
anything less than that,
it can know almost nothing, right?
But now if you take
the statistical postulate
of thermodynamics,
the ordinary canonical
probability distribution
that the world is in a given micro state,
given its macro state, and
you add that, and now you ask,
well, what can it know from
the physical laws together
with probability distribution?
Again, the answer is almost nothing.
If you think about it
carefully, you'll say,
well, of course.
That's because if I'm just looking
at my local environment here
and I'm asking what's gonna happen a day
or a month from now,
everything depends on
the exogenous influences
that are gonna impact
between now and then.
I mean, literally everything.
You can take any state,
at any finite fraction of,
or take any event or any finite fraction
of an interval into the future,
you can find a solution
to the physical laws
in which that event happens
and that event doesn't
just by putting the right
exogenous influences in.
Same in the backward direction.
And you know it's gonna be the same
in the backward direction,
because the laws are time symmetric.
But if you add a low
entropy initial state,
a low entropy state sometime
in the distant past, right?
Things change completely.
Now an agent that's situated,
looking at its local
macroscopic environment,
who has access only to
the macroscopic states
of things around it,
can know a whole lot about the past.
Why is that?
Because for any semi-ordered
state of its environment,
given a low entropy past,
a low entropy state in the distant past,
it can infer a lot about
what happened between
that distant past state and
the state of the system now.
That's the physical
underpinnings of what's going on.
When you look at a state like
a scar in a tree trunk or
a footprint in the sand or
a half melted ice cube
in a glass of water.
What you're doing is
effectively you're inferring
from its current state and knowledge
that it must be decaying from
some lower entropy state in the past,
that at some point somebody put,
it was in a more ordered
state than it is right now.
So that's what's really going on
in connecting sort of
the entropic gradient
with the kind of
information that's available
to an agent to use and
to kind of parlay into
information about what's going on
at other times.
Patently time asymmetric
has more to do now,
I mean, that's the step
that lets you go from
something about entropy
to something about
knowledge or information.
Did that answer your question, Priya?
- Yeah. Thank you, yeah.
- Now I've forgotten what the thread was
that we were talking about.
- Well, in general,
the worldly underpinnings of-
- Oh, right. Okay-
- Causal reasoning and inference, I would
wanna add some other possibilities
that I think are maybe also part
of the worldly underpinnings.
And I don't myself understand very clearly
how these might be related
to the thermodynamic gradient
and entropy increase, and so on.
And perhaps you might help me with that.
So one general feature
which seems to be present in our world,
and is incorporated in a whole
lot of physical reasoning
is some sort of notion of
the effect of independence often enough
of incoming influences, so to speak.
So we don't, for example,
if you have an accelerating
electrical charge,
you imagine that it will radiate outwards
with a spherical wave of
electromagnetic radiation.
You don't imagine that
you're going to see such
a wavefront coming in from a distance
and collapsing on itself into a point.
And the idea is that,
in the second case,
this requires some fantastic
level of coordination
between what we think of as
independent causal influences
and that, at least in most cases,
it doesn't happen in nature.
Now in that particular case,
I take it that there is
some sort of connection with
the same kind of physical
reasoning that underpins
the second law of
thermodynamics, and so on,
the kinds of assumptions
of Boltzmann made about
uncorrelated lists of molecular motions
immediately prior to collision.
So you can see the connection there.
But I think that's just
one of the things that
is among these underpinnings
of physical reasoning.
And a couple of other
things that strike me as
also present are the following.
One is simply that a lot
of physical systems have
a certain kind of modularity to them
in the sense that you don't really have
to take into account everything (chuckles)
in what's going on in
the external environment
in understanding their behavior.
And this is probably,
and probably the right
way to think about this
is it's the kind of,
in the physicist jargon,
a kind of effective independence
or effective modularity.
It isn't that the external
influences aren't there at all.
It's just that they're very
small and they can be neglected,
or maybe if they need to
be taken into account,
they can be taken into
account just by talking about
some very small number of variables
and parameters that are on the,
you think of as on the
boundary of the system.
You don't have to model everything
in the environment in
detail, in other words,
to get the behavior of the system.
And it just seems that a
lot of physical systems
in our world are like that.
Another notion that
strikes me as important
is the presence of what I
have called in a couple of papers,
approximate realization independence
or approximate conditional
causal independence,
where the idea is that at
least for many systems,
you don't have to know the details
of the physics all the way down
to understand their macro behavior.
So Leo Kandinov and Nigel Goldenfeld
give the example of modeling
the behavior of a bulldozer.
And they say, well,
you don't need to bring
in quantum chromodynamics
to understand the behavior
of a bulldozer.
You can model it
at a much higher level.
Now you could imagine an
alternative world in which
to model anything at all,
you had to understand
the physics at the very,
very deepest level.
And of course that would be a world
in which would be very
difficult to do science
or learn about relationships in nature.
But our world doesn't
seem to be like that.
There's a kind of,
a proximate decoupling often
between different scales.
And I think that's also something
that facilitates causal
reason in our world.
And I'm not sure exactly
how these are related
to the second law.
It isn't obvious to me that
they all just sort of fall out
of the second law.
And I wonder if you have
some thoughts about that.
- You see, there there's a lot there.
So first on
the microscopic sort of
chaos and macroscopic order.
So that's the full statement actually
of the past hypothesis.
So you assume that it's a
low entropy initial state,
so there's macroscopic
order, but other than that,
you assume uncorrelated micro condition
- Okay.
- On the modularity, so
this is an interesting-
- But can I just stop you for a second.
In connection with the past
hypothesis, and I have to admit,
I've never quite understood
the ins and out of that.
If you were just modeling the behavior
of a gas or something,
that it's a non-equilibrium state,
and it's going to equilibrium,
it doesn't seem like you would have
to bring the past type hypothesis
directly into the picture.
All you have to do is to talk about
the state of the gas at the moment.
And then you make
assumptions about, or
inquired ladenness or
equal probability over
all the micro states,
consistent with the macro
state and so on and so forth.
- So that's inferring its
future and inferring its past,
you need the past hypothesis.
- Okay. Okay.
- So if you just think of
it in time symmetric terms,
because the laws are time symmetric,
probability postulate is time symmetric.
So if you take those things
and evolve them forward,
you're gonna get exactly
the same results as
if you take those things
and evolve them backwards.
So if you didn't have the past hypothesis,
you ought to infer, not only the system,
if it's a gas with
partly collected in one corner,
you have to ensure not only
is the system just running
the dynamical laws forward,
gonna go to an increasingly
dispersed state.
You have to, inferring backward,
assume that's also coming
from a dispersed state.
So that in fact is collapsing
into a lower entropy stage,
just a chance fluctuation,
the probability distribution yields that.
So the past hypothesis
is an hypothesis that
when you're inferring back,
when you're kind of retrodicting
rather than predicting,
it's a brute postulate that
gets you the right state
in the distant past.
- Right.
- I'll just say one
more thing that connects
with our previous,
the talk about information.
That's also needed to
get things like that,
a semi-ordered state of the environment,
is in fact a record of
a more ordered state
in its distant past,
'cause otherwise the right thing to say
when you see footprint in the sand
is not that someone stepped there,
but that in fact it was
a chance fluctuation from
a beach at higher entropy.
That's the idea.
- Yeah, I don't know to
what extent our audience
is interested in the status
of the past hypothesis.
And as I say, I'm certainly no expert,
but I have to say that one
of the things that I find
a little puzzling about
the kind of inference
that you just described is that
it sounds as though the
claim is that we have
to assume the past hypothesis
if we're to take what appear
to be records of the past
as reliable at all.
But I take it, we do have
records of the early universe.
We think anyway
that we have some kind
of physical understanding
of why it's plausible
that the early universe
was in a low entropy state.
And this has to do with
complicated considerations about
the role of gravity in
the very early universe.
So it sounds as though
we, at least in cosmology,
and I'd actually be interested
in what Priya thinks about this,
we think that we have
information about the past
of the early universe and
its low entropy state that
it seems like we're assuming we have
some kind of independent access
to that that doesn't require
use of the past hypothesis.
- Can I say something about that?
- Maybe I'm just confused,
but that's my reaction.
- So I wouldn't put it in epistemic terms.
That's certainly the way
that Albert presents it.
This is something that we have to suppose
in order for our records to make sense.
I would say rather, look,
we live in a world in
which records are possible,
because the world started
out in a low entropy state.
And all of the things
that you're talking about
are inferences from the current state-
- From the current state.
Yeah, I agree with Jenann.
I think that would be the point of view
that I would take too, yeah.
- Okay, well that, I mean,
that is fine with me.
That makes perfect sense
as far as I'm concerned.
- So one way to see it is to say, look,
if we found out that there
was no past hypothesis,
we'd need to find new foundations
for all of those inferences,
because records would no
longer be underwritten,
the right inferences
to make from everything
that we see will have been undermined.
- But how would we find out that there
is no past hypothesis, presumably?
Wouldn't that require
some help finding out
that the universe apparently
wasn't in a low entropy state,
or at least wasn't in the
kind of low entropy state
that is described by the past hypothesis?
And wouldn't that in turn require
already taking seriously
our records of the past?
- We would, I mean,
all of this is just making explicit that
on which all of our
theoretical knowledge rests.
Any inference from present data
to what it tells us
about the past in one way
or another rests on the past hypothesis.
So when I said if we found out,
I meant if you released your commitment
to the idea that there
was a past hypothesis.
All of those inferences would
no longer be underwritten.
It's like you have a source of informa,
so this is the right way to think,
or at least the way that I think of it,
is making explicit the commitments,
the physical commitments
on which your reliance
on records rests.
And all of our theoretical
knowledge of the,
all of the information,
not only our direct
inferences about the past,
but the things that we
treat as the evidence
for our theories
depends on being able
to read the macro state
of systems as records of their past.
- Yeah, I guess, I mean,
one question I would have
in this connection is how,
I understand that if the universe were,
in its past, in a very different
state than it in fact was,
we wouldn't have records at all,
or they wouldn't be accurate,
or we wouldn't have human
agents, et cetera, et cetera.
But I guess the question
is how sensitive the kinds
of inferences you're describing are
to the exact details
of the past hypothesis?
That's one, I mean,
Is there, I mean,
I take it if the universe
somehow began or was in a very,
very early state of complete
thermodynamic equilibrium,
then we wouldn't be here,
et cetera, et cetera.
There would be nothing that
would be recognizable as,
of many interest anyway, as a record,
et cetera, et cetera.
But the fact that the universe
began in a low entropy state
or it didn't begin in a
complete equilibrium state,
that seems a little more
generic than the kinds
of assumptions that go
into the past hypothesis.
- Priya, did you want to?
- Yeah, I mean,
I don't know if
there are alternatives actually
in terms of just the frameworks
that are available for calculation.
I don't really know
what alternatives we would have
if we didn't start from
that generic assumption.
- Well, I'm not challenging
the generic presumption.
I was just wondering about whether we have
to assume anything as specific
as the past hypothesis in
the David Albert sense.
- It's not that specific actually.
- Yeah, I think it's,
I find it a little more sweeping
the past hypothesis.
And I know I agree with the Jenann's way
of phrasing it rather than David's.
But I think part of the, I've tried,
one can think about it in sort
of a counterfactual, right?
So what would have happened?
I mean, the thing is you
immediately run around
if you did not start from there.
So the counterfactual
way is not effective way
to understand this in this case, right?
Because you very quickly
will reach the point of the,
so we wouldn't be here
to ask this question if
that, this, this, that
had not happened, right?
So, yeah.
- And the very theories that we use to
sort of guide our sense of
those sorts of counterfactuals
is itself based on evidence,
inferences from which rests
on the past hypothesis.
So everything would be
up for grabs and in-
- Yeah, I was gonna say,
then everything becomes,
up for grabs, right?
So, yeah. It's a hard one.
I mean, this is a really
difficult question so.
- I mean, one way to ask it
would be, and this, I mean,
this isn't at all implausible that
sort of our theoretical
knowledge progresses
to a stage where we now
have a very specific idea
of what kind of initial state
that the universe was in.
I think what Albert is doing is saying
in order to underwrite
the sorts of asymmetries that are embodied
in our causal reasoning,
in our inferences to
the past is something,
we need something that
looks generically like
a state of macroscopic order in the past
or some sort of boundary
condition that will restrict
the states in the past
in such a way that those
inferences will be underwritten.
- Yeah, you need a
curtailment of the number
of possible states,
initial states from which you could start.
They could be a set. It
doesn't have to be unique.
But, I mean, there could be a set of them,
but I think I find it quite difficult
to understand even how we could explore
what that set could be,
because you very quickly run into the,
moving forward that
we wouldn't be here to
question blah, blah, blah,
for many of even those
other possibilities, right?
So it's pretty hard to
delimit that set as well.
- Does that help, Jim?
- Yeah, I mean,
I don't know whether we
wanna continue on this topic,
but I guess one of the
things that strikes me,
and I talk about this in
a paper on the Flagpole,
which you may know about,
is that if in, for example,
recent work in machine learning on
learning causal direction.
So the paradigm is something like this.
You have two correlated variables,
you have purely
observational data that shows
that they're correlated.
You can somehow exclude the possibility
that they have a common cause,
but you don't know whether
X causes Y or Y causes X.
Even in that apparently
very unfavorable setting,
there are in fact algorithms
and strategies that
will allow you to infer causal direction
with a fairly high level of reliability.
And what these procedures do
is that they exploit the fact
that in this kind of setup,
there is almost, at least
in a whole lot of cases,
it's going to be possible to find
an additional variable, call it Z,
which for example maybe
uncorrelated with X,
but correlated with Y, or
alternatively uncorrelated with Y,
but correlated with X.
And then you can explain that fact
to reach the correct conclusion
about causal direction.
So the correct direction
is the direction in which you have
a collider type structure in which
the two uncorrelated variables are causes
of the other variable.
Now in that kind of setup,
you're exploiting the fact
that there's a certain amount
of uncorrelatedness or
exogeneity out there,
but it's all very local.
You're not bringing,
now maybe at the end of the day,
it all depends on the past
hypothesis, I don't know,
but you're certainly not
kind of directly making use
of anything like the past hypothesis.
You're making use of stuff that is very,
as I say, very, very local to the system
that you are reasoning about.
And I guess I just think
it's of interest to try
to understand how those
inferences work and
what their warrant is and
what they assume about
what's true of the systems,
that you're using this
methodology to investigate.
And you can do all that,
I think, without necessarily bringing
the past hypothesis into the picture.
- Let me, I mean,
- I'm sorry, Jenann.
May I ask a question from the audience?
Swena was wondering about too, from Fall,
"How is the past hypothesis different
than the second law of thermodynamics?
Would both of you please explain?"
- Can I say something just
before I lose the thread?
- Sure. Sure.
- One thing that you have to keep in mind,
and I will come back to that question.
- Okay. Thank you.
- Jim, is that when people are looking
for foundations of thermodynamics,
in particular, the kind of
project that Albert's engaged in,
we're dealing with deterministic laws.
So any assumption that you
can state in local terms
will ultimately be stateable in terms
of kind of first principles
from initial conditions.
So in a way,
what he's trying to do is
trace those assumptions back,
or what he calls it the mother of all
sort of assumptions that you
need to make to generate all
of the sort of local, I
mean, the aspiration is,
though I don't, I mean,
if you ask me to give you a proof
that it's gonna work this way,
but the aspiration is it's
gonna be a single assumption
that's gonna underwrite all
of those more local inferences.
So what you're asking is, well,
I don't see that in all of
these more local inferences,
we're actually making
any necessary reliance
on the past hypothesis.
That might be true as a
matter of psychological fact
and as matter of practice,
but what Albert is trying
to do is precisely look at
all of the kind of local
assumptions that we make
and that underwrite things
like inferences from records
and scientific practice
and see if we can trace
those all the way back
to a single assumption about
what the initial conditions were like.
And it's gonna be, there
ought to be, I mean,
it's contingent whether there's
some simply stateable principle about
the initial conditions that will do that,
but there's gonna be some assumption
about the initial conditions,
because the laws are
deterministic in this regime,
that we'll be able to
capture all of those,
what you need to underwrite
all of the local inferences.
- Yeah, I mean, I guess
the only thing I would say
is that if David Albert wants
to make claims like that,
then with all due respect,
you should actually be looking
at these local procedures in detail,
and then telling us in some
detail how they're connected
to the past hypothesis.
And I'm not claiming that
is impossible at all.
I'm just saying that, well,
there's a project there.
And how that might be done is not,
at least to me, straightforward.
And again-
- We should answer the question
of the person and then,
'cause there's so much
more to say about this.
My inclination is to
come back and say more,
but we should also
answer the question that.
- Well, I haven't been looking at the.
- What was it, Ty?
- Sure, how is the past
hypothesis different
from the second law of thermodynamics?
- Do you want me to answer that or?
- Please, you or both.
- Okay, I'll do it quickly.
So second law of thermodynamics says
that no system decreases in its entropy.
The past hypothesis is an
hypothesis that is supposed
to generate the second law of
thermodynamics in conjunction
with the Newtonian mechanical laws
and the statistical postulate.
Does that answer your question?
- [Woman] Paul, did you
wanna type anything else-
- Right. Okay.
- Yes. Thank you.
- Well, Jim, now I am
gonna come back and say,
in fairness to David Albert,
I mean, this stuff is all,
this stuff is all very much in progress.
And what David was trying
to do is to make explicit
at really a very preliminary
qualitative level,
but much better than
anybody had done before,
the kind of thing that you need
to at least get going on
something that looks like
it would underwrite retrospective
as well as prospective inferences.
But you're absolutely right.
And I think he would be happy
to acknowledge that ultimately
the goal is to try to
understand all kind of reasoning
in terms of something that we
can connect directly and explicitly
to the causal asymmetries
captured in thermodynamics.
What's surprising about
thermodynamics is the degree
to which an incredibly
diverse body of phenomena,
all of the temporally
asymmetric phenomena you see
when you look around you,
fall under the scope of the second law.
If you can sort of understand,
even in qualitative terms,
how the second law can
underwrite something
like causal reasoning, which
does have built into it,
maybe the most fundamental kind
of temporal asymmetry,
then you've done something.
And that's what he was trying to do.
Priya, did you?
- What about the other candidates
for physical underpinnings
that I mentioned like-
- Right, I wanted to-
- Modularity and realization independence.
Do you see those also as-
- No, so let me, actually,
so, but first, Priya,
you came up for a second.
It seemed like you might
have something to add here.
- No, no, no. Not at all.
I was just nodding in agreement. Yeah.
- (chuckles) Oh, good.
- Yeah.
- So now we are leaving David.
I don't know what he thinks about this.
The modularity question is one
that I have found very interesting.
And so I'm just now gonna give
completely speculative idea,
sort of musings on that.
So one thing to say is it's for sure true
that just looking around us,
the systems that we actually see,
and I'm not gonna say in our universe,
but those systems that we see
around us in the biosphere
are not a random selection
of all physically possible
systems that there are.
So you're absolutely right.
That there's no reason that just looking
at the fundamental laws,
they should exhibit the
kind of modularity that we
in fact find in many of
the systems around us.
And moreover, those tend
to be the kinds of systems
that are targets for
scientific explanation,
and that are moreover
targets for the things like,
the formulation of laws or at least
the searching for dynamical
regularities in their behavior.
We do not try to sit down and write down
the dynamics of Jenann's right thumb
and Priya's ear lobe, and, right?
We don't do that.
So the real question is
why looking around us,
do we find all of these kinds of,
do we affine systems like that?
And at a much higher proportion
than you would expect
if you just thought that
the systems around us were
a random selection of possible
configurations of matter.
And the bias for the obvious
answer is that there's
a lot of evolutionary
pressure towards stable,
finding systems that-
- Right, so there's a contingency, right?
There's an evolution,
it's all contingent on
evolutionary outcomes, right?
- Right, so if you imagine, I mean,
you imagine the world is
throwing up complex systems
of all kinds.
Most of those are gonna disperse.
Some of those are
some combination of
self-organization selection
is gonna generate systems that,
because of the regularity exhibit,
and the fact that they largely manage to,
despite the kind of onslaught
of exogenous influences
to which they're, subject
at any given moment,
manage to maintain their
internal integrity and do it
that they need to persist,
those are the systems that
we're gonna find around us.
- But, yeah, quickly, to
ask for a clarification.
But, Jenann, isn't there implicit
in the way you phrased it,
the fact that evolution, whatever,
there were multiple,
potentially an infinite
number of outcomes.
And because of evolutionary pressure,
only some particular ones have survived.
But that does not mean
that all those outcomes
were not manifested.
They've just not survived in time.
They've not persisted, as you said, right?
But the other outcomes
might well have, I mean,
we have to leave explanatory room
for the fact that each one of them,
all the possibilities
were manifest, right?
- [Jenann] Right.
- We don't know otherwise.
I mean, well, we know it's finite
and it's not infinite, and
so on and so forth but,
yeah, I'm finding it a little confusing.
Like if we ask the
question of the biosphere,
should we just retreat and say, well,
every possible state for a system,
like a plant that evolves,
like the fig tree that
looks like this today,
there were an infinite variety or
a finitely large number
of variety in which
fig leaves were made.
And then they just did not survive
the evolutionary pressure.
So when we talk about outcomes and things,
should we say that everything is possible?
Or, I mean, should we
operate from that basis?
Or should we already operate from the fact
that we have an explanation,
there's some explanatory
power in evolution,
that not all possibilities
were actually actualized
and only finite number,
or one or whatever.
Yeah, but to me,
it seems like that's a
fundamental distinction you want
to make, because if one of them allows,
it's almost like anything-goes
explanatory power,
and the other is like a very directed,
particular kinds of explanatory power.
Am I being confused about
something else? I don't know.
I'm sort of going around
in circles trying to see
how we need to see the setup.
- Jim, did you have something?
- Oh, well, I mean, I do think
that looking at the matter
from the point of view
of a biologist,
the biologist does have
some sort of conception
of what's biologically possible.
And it's a smaller subset than
the set of all physical possibilities.
So, I mean, there, I think,
I mean, that's just part of, I take it,
I mean, the biologist may
not regard himself or herself
as restricted to the forms of life that
have actually ever existed in the past,
because there's certainly
a lot of current work
in biology involves
creating new biological structures
that have never existed in the past.
But I think there is some
sort of a broader constraint
having to do with the
biological possibility.
And it's a more constrained set than
just what's physically possible.
But to get back to the question of,
why do we find modular systems?
I agree that in nature,
I think part of the answer
to the question is that,
and so far as we're concerned
with biological systems
that has a whole lot to
do with the operation
of natural selection.
And I think that's actually connected
to the issue about
realization independence too,
because these systems,
typically the futures of their environment
that are important for
purposes of survival and reproduction
are at least somewhat macroscopic
or coarse-grained futures
of the environment.
And so the organism is sensitive to those
and maybe not to more fine-grain details.
And that means that in
modeling the organism,
we only have to look at the (chuckles)
coarse-grain features of the environment
and coarse-grain features
of the organism itself
rather than more fine-grain details.
So if I'm
an early hominid,
I wanna be responsive
to the fact that there's
a large predator nearby me,
but I don't have to make
fine-grain discriminations
about the exact configuration
of the molecules
in that a Siberian tiger or whatever it is
that is approaching me.
And then in addition to that,
there are the things about
stability and so on and
in the human nervous system,
you don't want the operation of our brains
to be incredibly sensitive to
small quantum mechanical fluctuations,
and so on and so forth. And so we have,
natural selection has ensured
that that's not the case.
So in the case of biological organisms,
I think you do have a story
about natural selection also
and just about our size as it were,
our scale that
explains why you get
some kind of modularity
and realization independence.
It might be that the correct
story about those things
for non-biological systems has
to be a little bit different.
I don't know.
- Can I add something to that though?
Because it nests right
with what you were saying.
If you ask,
and this is something that I
wondered about for a while too,
if you ask,
is there some increase in fitness
that one would get by being
able to see right down
to the microscopic fabric of the world,
and in particular epistemic fitness,
would it add to my ability
to predict microscopically
if I had microscopic rather
than merely macroscopic access
to the systems in my environment?
It turns out, for reasons
that are directly connected
to the past hypothesis,
that the answer is no.
And the answer is no precisely because
of the microscopic, okay?
So one of the interesting and important
and profound things,
and surprising things about thermodynamics
is the one that you pointed to.
There's no reason to think
from first principles
that there should be
any kind of prediction
at the macro level that wasn't
sensitive to microscopic.
The fact
that there are laws of thermodynamics,
so as we can formulate
macroscopic generalizations
that are insensitive to the
microscopic underpinnings
is surprising, but it also means,
because it means that
they're robust in the face of
whatever's going on microscopically.
But it also means that those
are the very generalizations
that we rely on to predict the future.
So having more information
about the microscopic state
is not gonna be parlayable, so to speak,
into increased macroscopic
prediction about the future.
- Right, and so you're arguing that
this is why sort of the modularity,
this is where the modularity comes in,
that you don't really
need to have descriptions
for every possible,
at the microscopic level for any sort
of macro phenomenon, right?
- Yeah, I mean, that's clearly true.
And I get the kind of
reasoning you were describing,
Jenann, has a role to play in that,
but I guess I'm wondering
if that's the whole story?
- Oh, most certainly
not. No, I think, yeah.
- Does it have something
to do with the character of
the generalizations themselves
at the different levels, okay?
So, you know-
- I'm sure.
No, no, no, I think you're
thinking that everybody
who's in the discussion
about thermodynamics said
it's far more developed than it is.
I mean, it's really,
everybody knows that
there's so many things
that we're only just
beginning to get a bit
of a qualitative grip on.
But you're right.
I mean, even understanding
the target general,
the target explananda much
less the precise nature
of the thing that's gonna
be doing the explanation,
and whether or not it's something
that we can subsume under
the past hypothesis,
are completely open questions.
And I think almost everybody
would acknowledge that.
- So if this is sort of a
natural moment to ask a question,
Ty, did you want to read
out Ferdosa's question?
- I think too, sure.
He's quoting from "Causation
with a Human Face," Jim.
There's no well-defined
notion of an intervention
on the spin state of one of
the separated particle pairs
with respect to the other
in EPR type experiments.
This would represent a
limitation on the application
of an interventionist account
of causation, end quotation.
So Ferdosa's asking,
"Would either of you care
to address this dilemma
if indeed it is one?"
And he says he know we're not
discussing quantum mechanics.
- Jim, did you, since that's from you.
I'm happy to, but I think
probably you're the person.
- Okay, so that, just to clarify,
that was from a paper of mine also
with the title "Causation
with a Human Face" written,
I don't know what, 10 or
15 years ago. (chuckles)
And I don't, in present,
subscribe to all of the views
about causation in physics
that I defended in that paper.
The paper's different
from the forthcoming book,
but I will try to say
a little bit about this
and the question of whether this is
in some sense of limitation on
broadly interventionist
conception of causation,
I don't think so.
I mean, one of the things that is clear
in EPR type setups
is that you cannot,
by intervening on one of the
correlated particle pairs,
causally influence the behavior
of the other particle there.
Okay, this is a kind of
no signaling resolved.
And so you certainly don't want the,
I would've thought,
the outcome to be that there's,
or the correct way to
think about the situation
to be that there's some causal connection
between the two separated particle pairs.
That would violate locality,
special relativity,
et cetera, et cetera.
So if it's right that there's
no well-defined notion
of an intervention that you can carry out
on one of the pairs,
then the interventionist account
yields the correct answer,
that there's no causal connection there.
So I would see that as a virtue
of the interventionist
account, not a limitation.
But I will defer to the experts
on quantum mechanics soon
who will know more about
this subject than I.
- 100% agreement.
And it goes very much with the idea that
the causal relationship
part of the surface fabric
of the world.
And there are things that emerge
when you have the right sorts of relations
between interventions and outcomes.
- Yeah, I mean, it's certainly,
at least the way I'm
thinking about things,
and maybe Jenann too,
that it's an implication of this whole way
of thinking about causation,
that there may very
well be physical systems
for which the kind of
causal analysis that we're
employ in other kinds of contexts
is just inappropriate.
Because the preconditions
for the application
of that kind of reasoning
just aren't present
in the systems in question.
So another question I thought
we might discuss, Jenann,
unless someone else wants
to jump in and discuss-
- I don't see anything, Jim,
so go ahead and proceed, yeah.
- So you and I are both,
I think, self-identified pragmatist
of one variety or another.
Could you say something, Jenann,
about what are the distinctive commitments
of your version of pragmatism and
how does it contrast with
other sorts of possibilities?
- I'm not sure that I have
any definite take on what sort
of pragmatist I am.
I tend to think that
we're natural creatures
in a natural world.
Our minds were made to
allow us to cope, not copy,
as Rorty famously said.
And many of the notions that we use
to represent the world,
even the ones that are kind
of psychologically most basic for us
in terms of how we represent the world,
are just part of a user
interface that was designed
to optimize our chances of getting around
into feeding and mating opportunities.
So in that sense, I'm a pragmatist.
That sort of pragmatism,
I think, is just a
consequence of naturalism.
And it's one I was driven to.
It was never a first principle for me.
It was more one that I was
driven to you just by trying
to understand how to fit creatures
into creatures like us into the world
as it's described by physics,
and to reconcile the
manifest image of the world
with the image that
physics presents to us.
So that's the way that I think of it.
Also, I mean, something
else that you've brought up
that I think is right, which is
the need to bring the
subject back into description
when we're trying to understand
even the most basic notions that we use
to describe the world.
And, I mean, in physics, I
think this becomes clear.
So I come at, from a very,
I started out being a fundamentalist
about physics thinking
the world is the way that
physics describes it,
but there are all these
problems coming up in physics.
Places where some feature of the world,
some feature of our
experience of the world
or the first-person
perspective of the world
or the everyday common
sense view of the world,
that's somehow not locatable,
or findable in the view of the world
as it's described by physics.
And in all of those cases or
all of the ones that I've-
- And also, Jenann, I mean,
even this fundamental thing, right?
With quantum physics, which is the sort of
the alleged clean separation
between the subject
and the object, the
observer and the observed,
when that gets disrupted as well, right?
- Right. 100%, yeah.
So one finds that
the attempt to give us
sort of God's eye view
of the world fails in ways that demand
that you bring the subject back in.
- So I had a question
for both of you.
This question about,
I've been thinking about the modularity
that Jim mentioned, right?
That you can restrict
yourself to a certain level,
macroscopic level about,
I think it was the Kandinov
quotation that you said.
You don't need to know QCD to understand
how the bulldozer works.
But, I mean, is that reflecting something,
is that reflecting that the laws of,
is reductionism somewhere in there
as a feature of the laws?
I mean, is that what it's about?
- Were you asking Jim or me?
- Yeah, well,
so, I mean,
I'm not sure quite what you
mean by reductionism but,
I mean, the way I think about
it is it isn't that I'm not,
and I assume this is the
way that Kandinov et al
would think about it too.
It's not as though you have
sort of emergent new physics
at the bulldozer level
or something like that.
It's rather more that you just don't have
to take into account
certain kinds of information
to model the behavior of bulldozers.
So it's a feature
of the world and our
fear rising that we can
drop certain kinds of
information, there's.-
- So some epistemic sufficiency?
It is sufficient to
just know Newton's laws
to understand what the bulldozer is doing,
and you don't need to know QCD or QED?
- Right, right, and I think
this is related to other
kinds of generic facts,
or, I guess, really sort
of semi-mathematical facts
that are pertinent here.
And, I mean, so you,
you can very often have
a situation with a
funneling kind of structure.
At a very, very fine-grain level,
some set of variables are
relatively highly correlated
with one another, but if you
coarse-grain in the right way,
coarse-grain the variables,
you can produce outcomes where
you have just a much
smaller number of variables
to begin with and you have lots
of other stuff just becomes independent
as a consequence of the coarse grainy.
So, I mean,
one of the things that I
see to be characteristic
of causal inference is we're
exploiting independencies
that exist in the world,
both statistical independencies
other kinds of independencies
of a more causal character.
And the notion of independence
is very much a notion
that's tied to ideas
about level and scale.
So something can be,
and you're modeling at an
incredibly fine-grain level.
It can look as though everything
is dependent on everything else.
As you move to a more
coarse-grained level,
you get, as I say, a
smaller number of variables,
and you get other stuff, in a way,
kind of effectively irrelevant.
And effective here, in the sense,
in which a physicist, I take it,
would use the notion of higher-
- And so, I mean, that's where
this idea of an effective theory, right?
So that you can treat some
variables as extraneous,
and then you can formulate,
you understand the behavior
with a paradigm number of
variables that are independent,
as you said,
and that they are sufficient
to give you explanatory power,
predictive power, and so on.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I think that's what I meant
when I was trying to say reduction,
you reduce reductionism
and sort of an implementation
there of, yeah.
- Yeah, so that's the sort
of picture that I have.
You're looking for what a statistician
would call sufficient
statistics. (chuckles)
Where you have something that
is much higher dimensional,
and you're trying to reduce it
down to a smaller dimension,
but the smaller dimension still retains
the relevant information that you need
for understanding the macro behavior
that you happen to be interested in.
So that's the general
general picture that I have.
And I must say that, I mean,
philosophers have, of course,
all sorts of ideas about
theory reduction, and so forth.
I don't really see that a lot
of what the philosophers have
to see about theory reduction
relates all that closely
to what I just described,
which seems like it's more of
the relevant thing in
understanding how theories
at different levels or scales
are related to one another.
Let's see if something
else showed up in the chat.
- Yeah, I'm just scanning the chat and
I don't see any further
questions from the audience.
So then, I guess, before we close,
are there any final sort
of comments or quotes
that both of you would like to share?
- Thank you for having us.
(Priya chuckles)
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah.
Yeah, thank you so much to both of you
for taking the time and
sharing your thoughts.
And these are very, very
important foundational questions.
And as our audience
probably realize that there
is no conclusion, final answer.
These are evolving in
terms of how we think
and how we even frame
the questions, right?
How we frame them and pose them.
So I just wanna take this
opportunity to thank you both
on behalf of the Franke Program
and The Inference Project.
And I want to thank the
audience for being here
on a Saturday afternoon.
So thanks very much, and
see you all soon. Bye.
- Thank you. Bye, Priya, Bye, Jim.
Thank you.
- Thank you. Bye
- [James] Bye. Thank you.